one thing I learned about New Mexico is
you don't have to be white to be white
trash life on the road
it's tacos egregores representing guns
and peace I can't apply sweating with
the London blackbirds spellcheck
straight wrestlerettes punks in the
front making out for yourself and never
likes to enjoy more leading merchant
tried the rental car has another
megachurch ting juicy Spadina 50 cell
phone it's all one big Law & Order
thanks for tuning in the road stories
podcast everybody I'm your host Marie
Blair Ianno we are part of the all
thanks Comedy Network what's going on in
all things comedy this week I don't know
I have nowhere near the whole things
comedy studio as you listeners know I am
in Santa Fe New Mexico more on that in a
minute I'm very excited for this episode
because it is with one of my dearest
friends one of the funniest people I
know kira soltanovich
she had dropped by the studio to do some
recording on her own podcast and I was I
figured hey as long as you're here let's
record some Road stories some stories I
haven't heard before and it's great it's
really fun I love when I sit down with
Kira she's hilarious she has a special
out on amazon.com check it out I think
it's called you did this to me
so it's so funny she's such she's really
one of my favorite comedians and every
time I tell like young comics especially
female comics for some reason that I'm
good friends with Kara they're like oh
my god she's one of my favorite
comedians I want to be just like her
when I get older so stick around for
that she's really hilarious now this is
uh this is the New Mexico update I've
been here as you get listeners know I've
been here for I'm going to be here for
all of July I have been here for two
weeks and it is turning into Groundhog
Day
pretty much baby actually it's more like
Martin Sheen from Apocalypse Now you
know I wake up every morning
santa fe [__]
I wake up there's nothing
I'm here two weeks now in between gigs
you soldier
[Music]
all right so maybe it's not that bad
but you get the point the days are
bloodied and together its I booked a lot
of gigs surprisingly and I'll tell you
more about that but a little bit how my
day goes is I take my kid to camp summer
kay it starts at like 7:30 or 7:40 it's
ridiculous how early this camp starts I
come back I do some work you take a nap
at the gym and then a lot of the
stuntmen who are working on this movie
my wife's movie are staying in the same
place we're staying and so I meet them
out by the pool and there they're like
combination stuntmen horse Wranglers I
guess they're from a ranch up in
Valencia or Santa Clarita California and
they're out here for the movie so I hang
out with them by the pool with drink
beer will make America great again
it's not that bad it's it's alright it
gets a little mind-numbing after a while
I did manage to book what I thought were
going to be some horrendous gigs and
don't get me wrong they they had some
horrendous moments but they turned out
to be fairly fun and deaf and fairly fun
let's just say that well first off I
booked this casino way south of Santa Fe
man it's like a four-hour drive but I
don't care it's like driving Vegas and I
Drive Vegas you guys know that to work
in Vegas and it's called this casinos
called the end of the mountain gods
alright it sounds like a chapter out of
Lord of the Rings or something man at
the end of the mountain gods and I am
just dreading this gig the whole way to
all four hours listening to 80s on 8 on
Sirius XM just going why did I do this
why did I agree to do this I can't
believe I'm doing this I'm going to the
end of the mountain gods and I'm telling
you when I say this place is in the
middle of nowhere it is in the middle of
nowhere we're talking I take a major
highway for about two hours I turn off
onto a two-lane highway for another hour
and then basically a dirt road up the
side of a mountain for an hour back onto
a paved road that winds through the
mountains nobody else on the road
through the mountains you come over this
cresting hill down the hill and then
I'm this massive massive resort stuck in
between these mountains I mean this
thing is huge it's got a massive lake on
it a huge golf course
beautiful casino what do you call those
just giant glass windows in the back
overlooking the mountains I was like oh
my god where did this come from but it's
a casino gig so Magary the casino is
nice but the gig you know the thing the
shitty thing about casinos is be if
they're not in the showroom if you're
not playing the big showroom then
they're usually in a bar or a restaurant
that is open to the casino so you can
hear all the gambling and the chica
chica chica chica from the slot machines
and the goddamnit I just lost my kids
college fund you hear all that [__] so I
was again beautiful you know I'm
dreading the show that night so I go
down for sound check at five's I check
in I take a nap I go down for sound
check at 5:30 because you always go to
sound check and it's not like that at
all it's in a little it's in a
restaurant bar closed off to the casino
it has its own cell it's basically a
club a club within a casino so I'm like
all right sweet this is going to be a
good gig and it turned out to be a
really fun gig we had a big audience of
a big audience there really respond
they're a little tight you know they're
pretty religious it's weird we're very
close to Texas but we're on a
reservation so you got the Texas Trump
supporters then you got the Native
American anti Trump people so it was a
nice mix of both but let me tell you the
cool all right let me tell you the
shitty thing that happened first of all
I go down there we're doing the show I
meet the middle act and I won't say
their name or anything like that but
they're nice and we're talking and we're
getting along and the emcee goes up does
his time a guest spot goes up very funny
guy out of Santa Fe Masari out of El
Paso I don't remember his name Sam
something and then the emcee brings up
the middle act and the middle acts
supposed to do 30 and I never do this I
never wave my headliner deck around I
never make demands or anything like that
I'm just a roll with the punches kind of
guy as you
no but she's supposed to do 30 and about
20 minutes of silence and two or three
people leaving I tell the sound guy I'm
like lighter get her offstage I'll make
up her time she's walking you gotta get
her out of here so he likes her I tell
the emcee to do two minutes of material
just kind of get the room going again
and he does I go up we have a great
anyway I have a really good time ever
really good time so that was the drag it
was a bummer for her I know she's just
I'm not going to say she's a terrible
comic because that's not fair I think
she is new in the middle spot and didn't
wasn't sure how to handle it I had a
long talk with the Booker about about
her and he's like hey you want to give
her some tips like no I don't want to
give her some tips I can't just call and
say hey you had a shitty set I wanted to
tell you what you did wrong like I'll be
happy to talk to her if you want to set
that up but that's a whole nother thing
so the cool thing about this show at the
Inn of the mountain gods is I know you
guys for those of you don't know last
year I did a tour of the Middle East and
perform it for the troops and while I
was at one of the gigs way out in the
middle of the desert in Bahrain or
someplace like that I think it was
boring outside of Bahrain one of the
comments one of the comics one of the
military guys comes up to the green room
it says hey
I do stand-up when I'm at home you know
I kind of dabble in it or whatever would
you guys mind if I did a guest set and
so I left it up to the other guys
because I was new to this Booker I
didn't want to make you know throw up
comics that I'm not supposed to and then
get pissed off the Booker never work
again so everybody agreed to yes you can
go ahead so he went up he did five
minutes open the show or whatever it was
great cut to last week at the end of the
mountain guides somewhere in New Mexico
on the borderline of Texas I think which
by the way I didn't know do Mexico
border like Texas I'm sitting in the
back of the club waiting for the show to
start and the emcee walks in and who's
the emcee
the military guy from Bahrain the guy
who did a guest set in Bahrain over a
year ago he walked in and he's like hey
Mari what's up and I knew exactly it was
like oh [__] Erin what are you doing
here so it was really cool
he stateside he's doing a lot of
stand-up it was just really cool to see
a guy that you met one night in the
Middle East a year and a half ago and
come to a gig and see him MC and he did
a great job MC and so good for you err
and it was good seeing you so that
turned out to be the end of the mountain
gods it was great I stole a lot of DVDs
which I'm sorry I saw a lot of CDs which
was great and then on the right home now
when I say I was in the middle of
nowhere I was in the middle of nowhere
I'm driving home at night I'm driving
back that night so I can take my kid to
camp the next morning because my wife
goes to work so early I don't know I'm
in the middle of nowhere its pitch black
it's dark I'm following my Google Maps
my phone freezes I have to reboot it I
reboot it no signal no Wi-Fi I'm in the
middle of nowhere I have no idea where
the [__] I'm going I can't get Google
Maps I can't get anything man folks leo
[__] abrade there's no phones there's no
there's no lights of houses or gas
stations or hotels or anything so I just
kept driving down the road just knowing
I just need to go this direction I need
to go this direction and then some guy
kind of like was following me you know
kay turned onto the road behind me and I
waved my flashers out of my waved him
over and he told me how to go but man I
was that was scary though it was a rough
night being in the middle of nowhere not
knowing where you're going so that was
the first gay go so yeah you know I
comes up on that gig and then last this
weekend actually I just got back
yesterday I think I iced to find out do
a to do a a casino like I I thought I
signed on to do two nights at a casino
here in New Mexico and I wasn't going to
do it because it was the middle spot and
you guys know in the hood liner what's
up but my friend ally Breen and you guys
know Ally Breen she was been on the show
several times she's a good friend of
mine she's hilarious she's out of New
York I've worked with her a hundred
times I haven't seen her in two years
because she's in New York well she was
put in the headlining
I guess for the Booker she this is her
first headlining spot to see if she can
headline then he'll headliner so I'm
like you know what it's alley I love her
I'll do the middle spot it would be
great to hang out with a friend we'll go
we'll do these kegs and it was fine it
was great dolly did great I it was it
was good we basically split the time
because it was a two-man show so he
basically did 40 or 45 each or something
like that it was a lot of fun I have it
open to show in a while so that was a
little rough but other things had went
really good but here's the problem so I
wanted to take my podcast equipment and
do it on the road
like I usually do but it would just got
so she missed her plane out of New York
and I was getting picked up in Santa Fe
to go to Albuquerque to catch to meet
her at the airport and where we could
pick up the rent-a-car and then I
couldn't get to Albuquerque and I did
want to rent a car and drive it an hour
to Albuquerque drop it off there and
then there but there was a train so I
went through the train but the train
didn't leave until you had to leave like
6:00 a.m. but I had to drop my kid off
it was a totally and then a dice Mitch
and Ally missed her plane I don't know
if I'm much of that or not and it's but
anyway I finally I get there I get to
the airport we we get the rental car
it's great we
I don't know what happened but we
literally the show started at 8:00 we
literally got there at 7:56 it was who
has pulled it like the Booker's calling
us we're trying to call the casino
manager to tell him but we can't get no
signal because we're in the middle of
[__] nowhere and they're panicking
like where are you where are you but we
pulled in and we just like Acts asked
him to hold the show for five minutes we
just kind of got acclimated and it was a
pretty good show is in a back showroom
it was the spotlight was weird some dude
called my wife a [__] yeah it was a
good time it was a good time but as
we're going back to our hotel I look at
our itinerary and I scroll down and I
noticed we're doing two shows but we're
not doing two shows at this casino we're
doing this casino and then tomorrow
night we're doing a show in Montrose
Colorado which is about three and a half
hours away and we're like 1:00 we had to
count like nobody when it was pitch to
me it was we're doing - you know you can
do two shows and you'll do with Ellie oh
that's great they didn't tell us that it
was a show here and then a show in a
completely different state so ha ha [__]
so we we mapped it out and then we got
on the road the next day and drove and
it was great oh my god dude Colorado is
beautiful New Mexico is not if New
Mexico is brown and flat and hot man we
drove through when we got into Colorado
who was like it instant scenery change
man it was slush it was green we drove
through these mountains that were like
fiery red we drove along this two-lane
highway through these mountains that
literally literally next was 200
300-foot cliff drop-off I mean no
guardrail either I said it's the most
beautiful suicide trap you've ever see
because you just start looking at the
scenery in the next thing you know you
veer off the road and you plunge to your
death
that's what I'm assuming it didn't
happen to us but that's because Ali was
driving the whole time but it was
beautiful so we end up in in Montrose
Colorado I don't know if you guys have
ever been in Montrose Colorado but if
you've ever watched sons of anarchy
pretty much the same thing there anyway
I'm sure there's a chapter or sons of
anarchy and Montrose California and so
we're getting put up in a bed and
breakfast now I have never been in a bed
of breakfast I don't like the idea of
beds and breakfast --is I don't it's
like going into somebody's house and
paying to sleep in their room and then
di completely uncomfortable so we're
going to drive back from Montrose that
night but we Google Maps did six hours
so I am now six hours away from my home
actually I take it back I'm six hours
away from my hotel by the way uh living
in a hotel and then going on the road
and stayin and hotels and then coming
home back to a hotel really [__] with
your head man it really does don't make
me play the end by the doors again
because it really [__] with your head
so it turns out we're saying we have to
stay in this bed and breakfast because
we don't want to drive the six hour
death trap of a highway back at night
because we would surely just die so we
decided we get up early and drive back
from the bed-and-breakfast where's the
show you asked where was the show
remember I said we're staying in a
bed-and-breakfast it was in the
bed-and-breakfast I performed at a
bed-and-breakfast I've never been inside
a better breakfast I've never performed
at a bed-and-breakfast I did them both
in one night where in the bed breakfast
on the porch overlooking the backyard
how was it it was good wasn't great it
wasn't bad I mean this listened this
could have gone awful but apparently
they've been doing comedy here for seven
years people come out to this
bed-and-breakfast for the comedy they
pay a hefty cover I was very surprised
so much they paid to get him by the way
we're talking comedy club prices and
yeah we're pretty good nobody called my
wife a [__] which was great
I had some woman some woman kept calling
out she kept calling out and she
wouldn't stop and as I was wrapping up I
shut her down a few times and nicely and
as I was wrapping up just she started
calling out again and I noticed that it
looked like she had braces now you guys
know I have braces on my teeth so I said
you know all right I apologize but I
have to ask you do you have braces on
your teeth it looks like you have braces
for a mirror and she said no and then
she smiled at me she'd have braces she
had the god-awful greatest brown black
teeth I've ever seen in my life so I was
a lot of backpedaling getting out of
that one well you have a lovely smile
anyway so the shows went pretty well it
was so great to see Allie Breen this is
how this is how much fun this gig was
traveling with Allie was we were six
seven eight nine ten we probably logged
in twelve hours in the car together not
once did we turn on the radio we just
talked and had a good time and caught up
and [__] on other comics and we added up
in these like we went we stopped in
Durango Colorado it was one of the
cities we stopped and we stopped at a
place called Silverton man it was like
taken out of a movie see it would it
looked like all the buildings had to be
built in like the 1800s and it was it
was just great we stopped off we got
some ice cream we're taking pictures in
front of the mountains and it was like
we decided that we were on this like
platonic honeymoon that newlyweds go on
so we dubbed it the platonic comedy
honeymoon tour actually we dubbed it the
comedy honeymoon tour and then when I
post about it on Instagram people who
don't follow the show or like what what
happened did you get married where's
Mary what's going on with your wife so I
had to go back and call it the platonic
comedy honeymoon tour people don't have
a
man I don't get it but it turned out to
be great and it was great seeing Ally
and she was hilarious and I'm here for I
think I'm coming back to Los Angeles
August 1st
Oh something oh I'm actually I'm going
back to Los Angeles next weekend so I'll
be at the Hollywood improv on Friday
night I'm flying in for that and
possibly do a couple dates on Seth
Meyers and I'm waiting to hear back from
the Ice House on the comedy magic club
deducible or so if you're in town I want
to come and hang out be nice to see some
friendly faces over the next two weeks
I'm Gary bright well comedian Gary
bright will would be sitting in as host
of the road stories podcast so he's
lining that up right now he's recording
with some Gary's great he's hilarious
like I said he when I do TV spots he
helps me write him out Yelp's with
regular jokes we're trying to get stuff
going together
he's a good guy he's really funny he
knows everybody so I'm hoping he's
lining up some good guests so Gary
bright will will be guest hosting the
podcast over the next two or three
episodes I'll be opening up the podcast
with some New Mexico updates and any
questions you guys have regarding New
Mexico feel free to send them to me and
remember I'm at Murray V on Twitter I'm
Murray V comedy on Instagram like my
Murray valeriano Facebook page Murray
blaring economy Facebook page you get
all the updates and everything or just
friend me on Facebook who knows I reach
the five thousand I cancel a bunch of
people reach it again cancel bunch of
people anyway you guys I'm keeping my
sanity here in New Mexico feel free to
tweet at me feel free to shoot me emails
through my website or Facebook keep me
entertained let me know if there's
something in New Mexico I need to see
I'm really excited for you guys to
listen to my talk with carousel Tana
[__] right here don't forget to check
her out I think that's about it so so
far so good New Mexico I will check in
with you guys next week
thanks for listening so our song AGGA
theme song getting the road stories
podcast with marie hey it's the road
stories podcast with miry you are so
regretting that when I put burn that to
an mp3 and I posted on your Facebook
page I will not regret so we're
correct it's coming no regrets in life
no regrets in life this is kira
soltanovich chair have you been oh
thanks for coming over and talking to me
it's like another water you want another
water uh yes of a brogrammer
okay yeah are you sure it's empty you
know for somebody as crunchy and hippy
as you are you're contributing a lot to
the landfill
well you gotta pick and choose oh okay I
see
I know it's hard it's hard to be crunchy
sometimes I I I'm actually sorry this is
not a good sound for microphone what are
you doing here blasting you know like we
don't do cloth diapers oh but there are
those crunchy crunchy moms are like I
would never do that to the landfill I'm
like ah [__] it I don't care I'm
definitely a tree hugger but then I have
a line I was flying up to the Bridgetown
Comedy Festival Liberty on Comedy
Festival and I was on the plane wait
I've done that right oh yeah first I was
great in Portland yeah I did my
favorites of all I think I'm gonna do it
again this year and I've missed the last
couple years and I was flying up it was
like one of me afternoon and that's
having a scotch
sure let's having Scotch in the guys
like next me goes Wow
what do you do that you can drink scotch
at 1:00 in the afternoon I said well I'm
a comedian and I'm flying up to a
festival and I don't have a gig tonight
and I have a three-month-old this was
right after my son was born I have a
three-month-old and I'm just relaxing
he's just having a good time yeah I
don't need your [__] third degree
okay dude 9si that's part um he puts and
he's like oh you have a you have a three
a three month old I have a diaper
company ah that is environmentally
friendly so you don't you won't
contribute to the landfills I said oh
that's cause like I'd love to send you a
case I'd love to have a case closed no
I'd love to have a case of these
environmentally because I I've been a
member of Greenpeace and WWF since I was
like 18 I'm a vegetarian I was arrested
I have to do it
I would idolized Superfly Jimmy Snuka
man he was very strong and saved the
whales
it's unlike so I'd like yeah sure here
you can send them to the my p.o box
whatever and I gave him the address and
all that like six months later we get
this box of environmentally friendly
diapers was it a nightmare
oh there is a landfill named after Mary
valeriano Oh God I was like one look at
those and I look at my wife she's like
no [__] way
and you throw them out oh yeah you throw
away
I feel quick wait a second were these
cloth diapers they were worse than cloth
Peppers sable fur baby had a loose my
career they had a plastic outer coating
what yeah it's like a think of like a
plastic think like a plastic pull up
like a pee-pee pull up yeah
what snaps in it so you could snap in a
cloth diaper Oh like way too many steps
yeah no that's like you've lost me at
snaps okay I'm not snapping anything and
we just like you lost me a plastic yeah
we're like and it probably wasn't
plastic was probably some right who
knows whatever some hippy made in
Montana but those were like in the front
door out the back let's go ahead and
write to pampers yeah or Huggies yeah
that's kind of you got it that's again
that's a given I mean yeah yeah I
watched a little bit of a video clip of
a woman who her two years of garbage was
fit into Mesa in a little jar I saw that
did you see that yes it's [__] and
then she's and then the woman's like
questions and she's like sure it's like
uh what do you do about salt I make my
own what do you do about toothpaste I
make my own what do you do about
feminine products menstrual cup out done
don't even I can't stop the video I'm
like I don't to here anymore I don't
even want those I don't even I don't
want to hear those two words together
and I know that's not I don't have
anything to worry about but that just
have you seen the newest video on
Facebook that's going around where you
can turn your sperm on and off oh yes
that's been in this Dennis yes I've seen
that come on are you gonna put a switch
in your dick Oh
are you gonna put the light like a what
who is gonna put a light switch in there
taint you you know what I'm going to do
the clapper oh my god I wish there would
not be great if you could get an
erection that fast
oh just clap forever down down high just
clap
Oh as a comic that'd be embarrassing
every plot every blood well I don't have
to worry about them yeah sure sorry we
have to switch gears what happened I'm
so sorry you need to look I'm a stallion
well and you need to take the rain and
horse whisperer me because I don't know
where I'm going to feel kind of hot
[Music]
you told me one story on time about I
might I might have made it up okay
did you perform for a wedding one time
I've been a severed in several weddings
okay which one was this the one in the
field
oh my friend's wedding I don't know
maybe it was like muddy oh my god this
is gonna sound so weird
I've done a couple weddings in fields
with mud it was your what he means the
world where the dog got into the mud and
jumped into the eyes of the bride from
janab muddy muddy wedding dress probably
the one wait did I ever tell you I might
have told avatar you the gigs I did in
Iowa no oh this is a good one yeah okay
so I did a bowling alley in Iowa he
traveled to Iowa to do a bowling alley
look to each his/her own our bowling
alleys here I know but they weren't
booking me okay I didn't know it was a
bowling alley right but it was in the
middle of Iowa and it was called
Whitey's that's already yeah a bad sign
oh you're Jewish you know what they they
asked where my horns were I have had
someone ask if they could see my horns
yes
they met your boobs yes no real in Utah
really yes
this kid alright quick segue um oh I
have a good one
all right can I do this one George all
right I was in Utah ooh yes um and at
first I thought maybe my marriage
material wouldn't go over went very well
I guess what yeah they were all married
I did a college in Utah and everybody
there was mayor in the college the
college kids 18 years old married how
many was many many wives and many men's
many men's and women's okay no because
they can't have sex until they're
married oh they're getting married only
so they'll get married yeah they're like
yeah okay whatever so I'll find what
everyone assigned let's do it let's do
it I just want a [__] right and then
little do they know they get married and
then those go away barbar so they asked
me several times you know not to swear
not to curse I said don't worry no
problem I don't need to do that my acts
I don't worry but I would um you know
check into my hotel and there was a note
in my hotel saying welcome to you know
whatever whatever school right in Utah
and we don't remind you please no
cursing and no you know no foul language
and please keep it clean there's a note
in my hotel and I checked and I was like
all right I get it
Wow yes then I get a phone call from the
students picking me up to take me to the
school hey how's it going my name is
jebediah I'm married I'm 18 you know I'm
like you know the typical conversation
you have and we're picking up oh I just
want to remind you I said if you remind
me not to swear I swear to God whatever
God you believe in who found his chest
of jewels underground whatever in a cave
and in a cave I you're gonna really
drive me crazy please that you don't
have to remind me anymore so I was
reminded a few more times I come into
the campus right I get there
start walking down the hallways to the
venue the little room we're going to do
the stand-up in and make up signs you
know posters that they make up for the
comedian that's coming into town sure
advertising me kira soltanovich that's
my Sultana [__] soultana [__] built on
a [__] [__] [__]
VI TCH you guys have Google in your
pockets every person in here has the
universe in their crotch nobody thought
to maybe say is this really her last
name and can we say it we're not
supposed to sorry and they have it
written everywhere they have it down
every hallway so come see kira
soltanovich tonight so I was fuming I
was so ready you know like when you go
to a gig and you're and something
happens or they promise you something
and it wasn't there or they just it's a
[__] just nightmare gig and you just
you get to the stage and you're like I'm
gonna unleash on these poor bastards so
I get up on stage and there's a huge
Jesus enormous Jesus like awkwardly big
really yeah on stage yes that right
right in front of me so I can see this
in like three stories high this building
and it takes up the entire like it's
huge let me ask you this
yes as a Jew did you want to kill them
it's already been done okay yeah okay
fine I want to beat a horse good get
horses I mean a dead Messiah to chef
um you know and there's a huge Jesus and
I and the first thing I get up onstage
is like hey everybody thanks for having
me your name is Keira Sultana [__] oh
I'm not allowed to swear I'm so sorry
but that's my last name or is it or is
it who made the posters I want to see
the person that made the posters this
poor schmuck is sitting in the front row
and I looked at him I said do you have a
Mart phone or are you guys all like in
1987 here in Utah whose owner but
whatever he said is stupid 18-year old
face doesn't say mmm and I go okay pull
it up right now I want you to Google
just my first name right let's say you
don't like let's say Sultana [__] is
just out of your realm of consonants and
vowels I get it it's a hard last name
just put in Keira and just type in
stand-up comedy or even if I'm a funny
if I may be so bold write anything and
my name will come up I will do it now
now do it now I said do it now you
little [__] I can say [__] since you
guys have it written all over your
hallways and I used the word [__]
throughout my entire set the entire
afternoon times not to swear I was like
well [__] it you just gave me gave me my
passport to swear Ville I'm high-fiving
you right now
thank you man it's not on a [__] yeah
that's gonna I was I was yeah so that
was okay that helped me that story I
never told you that one ah oh great yeah
yeah they were pissed I bet they were
really mad at me both got a story on so
so um I want to brag uh-huh but I'm at a
place in my career where I will work a
bowling alley in Iowa and get paid
dozens of dollars oh well I was bragging
now upon dozens there's a bowling alley
I don't care about the city it's not
Dubuque but it's another one that
doesn't matter um actually the Buch is
kind of a cute little town it's kind of
sweet but it was outside of normal human
parts of Iowa and it was it was
frightening I was a frightening part
whities bowling alley I didn't know the
bowling alley
what they did was genius so smart you
know where the pins are
all
at the end of the lane yes they put a
stage over there to cover where the pins
are
right to cover that area they put a
stage okay okay uh but kept the lane so
people are sitting a bowling lane away
from the stage so if you try to any
crowd work
you're basically screaming like where
are you from what do you do are you guys
married down a bowling lane like so they
couldn't sit cool I don't know I don't
know why guys arts only so you got to
state where you would throw the ball
okay so you staged and that's where the
pins are where the pins are so they put
like a little stage over there
and they sat everybody back by the where
the return ball machines yes first of
all I'm thinking that is a long stage
because there's usually like 50 bowling
lanes no no they just covered only a few
okay yeah okay so you walk over like
from the back so I'm basically walking
like we're like in the olden times when
the guy would be back there
replacing the pins that's were enter
that's our green room excuse me sir I'm
doing a tight five and and there was a
faulty even though everything was turned
off there was like one faulty pin thing
that wasn't turned off and every once in
a while I would just go crash quick yes
and like reset bowling pins that were
not there but it was so earnest it was
like I'm just gonna do my job and I'm
just like nobody can second turn this
thing off a party in Iowa at a bowling
alley nobody can just throw me a bone
here so I did a gig it's as you can
imagine amazing oh I'm sure yeah I
standing over you know killed kill and
they did they stood and then they all
slipped was very slippery rolling
rolling means it's greased up and I'm
just ready to get out of there
I am just so ready to get out of there
and whitey the owner well that's his
name yes he comes up in a little
Caucasian yeah okay interesting
Wow good he comes up in his little like
rascal
let me guess Caucasian and fat you know
what he wasn't that fat really just lazy
I think just white just lazy
you know just like kind of rednecky and
just kind of yeah or maybe he had
something maybe you know muscular
dystrophy whatever he might yeah rickets
or just may just need a place to display
his rebel flag bumper session actually
he did have of course he didn't have one
us so he comes riding up in a little
rascal it's going I'm not kidding you
0.02 miles per hour it's going backwards
so that's how slow it is I go dude what
are you doing well rascal like you could
hear him 20 minutes away trying to get
to you he comes over and he goes he kind
of sounded like like a mix between Barry
Katz and Mitzi shore oh you know to me
is like you I want to pay you I go I
love to be paid are you gonna steal it
out of the strippers money like out of
their belt their little money bill I
forget to mention there were strippers
there wait why they were doing all the
side yeah hold on they forgot hold on
you really glossed over a huge part of
this story but American real strippers
let me hold on hold on let's back this
thing up I'm so sorry back to saying I'm
one point little sleep at one point at
what point are you on the stage and
doing your set and whitey comes do the
strippers enter no no okay so I'm so
sorry
so the strippers aren't strippers
they're just these girls kind of like in
this half like mess out kind of like a
you like a heroin lien so I kind of like
leaning over but they're in bikinis and
they have fanny packs so they're just
kind of meandering around between me
packs or like c-sections gone wrong
I mean since Ruby told colostomy bag
where you can put a dollar bill so
they're just kind of like swinging to no
music by the way to no music but they're
just swaying and walking between
customers and like putting like dollars
in their fanny packs so er worth the
cost
so they were not strippers per se they
were half homeless drunken women who
probably lived underground with whitey
with whitey probably yeah so um he's
like I have your money and I go great
whitey I'm ready to be paid but you have
to come with me to the office Oh No yeah
so like forever
well that's the thing I go alright let's
go and I'm walking he goes now get on
board
oh where do you want me to stand goes
Pat's his lap Oh get on and I go Oh
whitey no I'm too heavy I'm a big girl
there I'm like a sack of cement you know
I'm like you know what that's going to
hurt whatever cerebal palsey already
have or whatever is happening like
please don't make me do this I get on I
had to sit on his little hat his office
was probably 500 feet away sure it took
us three days
he was running that little rascal
unlike double-a batteries as
it was me horrible meanwhile that non
strippers with the colostomy bags are
like oh how come she gets to ride on son
how come she gets to ride on fun why do
you get my stomach doesn't leak but my
problems weaken again it will add us is
it leaking so dreadful and as you can
imagine we come into his office and it
looks like a pawn shop like there are a
trillion little gadgets and trinkets and
weird like Bozo it's just a garage sale
sure for ours are all for racists it's
just awful awful awful and I'm sitting
there and he goes and he bends down in
his little rascal into the safe I go
dude you're giving me like couple
hundred but look in the safe really come
on I will at this point take like an
Applebees gift card if I could just
leave like just get out of here and it
goes he gets my money because I'll take
you back I got it I got it I got it
thank you so much ever money in my
pocket I was out of there so fast I ran
I ran for my life because then I
realized these like really scary kind of
meth head guys they stand there knowing
that the comic just got paid cash oh and
you see them Ike's totally strung out
just as crazy glaze in their eyes and I
was like [__] I never ever before in my
comedy career thought I might get robbed
right except for at Whitey's bowling
alley in the middle of Iowa all I feel
bad for those strippers with the bags
now they're making out like bandits you
kidding me okay I will see a couple
hundred bucks a week you're fine live on
the road it's such a thing the doors
representing guns and be like kids of
like running with the run John Blackwood
spellcheck space-shuttle arrest
in the blood making out there your size
and midlife doing no more making
merchant tried the rental car has
another megachurch turn juicy vagina fit
cellphone is gone
one big law and order mara